después de días de espera en el mar
mediterráneo más de 800 migrantes
pudieron desembarcar el domingo en
sicilia el buque que los rescató el
cifor de una ong alemana fue finalmente
asignado al puerto de trapani y los más
de 800 rescatados del sinaí force
llegaron al puerto de trapani esto marca
el final de una exitosa misión de
rescate agradecemos a misión de
salvación por la buena cooperación en el
mar hasta juntos más fuertes la mayoría
de los adultos fueron trasladados a
otros barcos para que cumplan una
cuarentena preventiva contra el hobbit
19 mientras que unos 160 menores fueron
llevados a refugios en tierra muchos
procedían de áfrica occidental- egipto o
marruecos y son a bordo cerca 170
minorías hay unos 170 menores a bordo no
sabemos cuántos son no acompañados y
cuántos están con familias siempre hay
menores entre los migrantes que llegan
este año hay más en comparación con el
año pasado 7 mil 800 menores no
acompañados frente a 4600 en el mismo
período del año pasado también hemos
observado un aumento del número de niñas
de costa de marfil
de los de su periodo de lo de los cursos
llegando a trapani la ong si hay criticó
el silencio de las autoridades de malta
a las que el barco solicitó en los
últimos días un puerto destacó también
que el país insular de europa ignoró las
señales de socorro en su propia zona de
búsqueda cerca de 55 mil migrantes han
desembarcado en italia en lo que va de
año casi el doble de los 29.900
contabilizados en el mismo período del
año pasado